[Music]
what does magic sound like that's only
one of a million questions that those
who brought the world of Harry Potter to
film at the answer I don't envy them
when you bring a beloved story to life
viewer in a sense collapsing the
millions of movies that already exist in
the imaginations of readers into one it
may not be your intention to create a
definitive version but if you do your
job right that's what's gonna happen for
a lot of people so every little
technical question matters like this one
[Music]
though there are some precursors in
literature before Harry Potter film had
never really seen such a formalization
of magic such a variety of possible
spells cast with specific gestures and
feelings and if the filmmakers didn't
quite know what all that should sound
like they at least knew what they didn't
want it to sound
in preparation for the first film
director Chris Columbus told supervising
sound editor Eddie Joseph that he didn't
want anything modern futuristic or
electronic the Star Wars blaster and
lightsaber being I think key points of
reference and though the sound profile
of magic spells changed throughout the
series that was a mantra that subsequent
filmmakers and sound designers for the
most part held super for example here's
the very first juan 'magic in the series
unburrow magic I guess the filmmakers
use a technique here that they return to
again and again when the magic being
created has a specific sound already
associated with it they use that
in a lot of these cases this spell
doesn't really need a sound of its own
if the thing it's impacting is immediate
enough that'll do the job and there are
others like levitation that work just
fine silently but Harry Potter has
plenty of spells that do need sound
effects ones that don't have any obvious
connection to sounds in the real world
it's in these cases that the filmmakers
and sound designers get to be creative
in the first two films you can tell that
there was a fair amount of
experimentation going on here are all
the sounds from Sorcerer's Stone back to
back
now what did you hear in there I heard
some bushes some explosives some
firecrackers some electricity and even a
couple animal noises now take a listen
to chamber of secrets
what's interesting here is that the team
on the second movie appears to be
consolidating the styles from the first
movie into one what you could call the
explosive whoosh sound effect it sounds
like a combination of rocket boosters
explosives and air Jets and it's not
unreasonable to assume that this style
may have dominated the series going
forward if not for a radical change in
the prisoner of azkaban
ridiculous Alfonso Cuaron and his team
completely redesigned the sound of magic
for the third movie gone are the
explosive whooshes replaced with soft
flute e sounds for just about every
spell it makes the magic feel less
aggressive and more mysterious like it's
just a wisp of wind on the air that
serves as a good foundation from which
the movie builds its central spell the
Patronus charm the Patronus is a
projection of your happiness a positive
force built from your fondest memories
that repels Dementors which feed on
despair in Azkaban the Patronus is built
out of voices a chorus of angels that
fits with that heavenly projection of
your soul without fear
I think the prisoner of azkaban freed up
the rest of the filmmakers in the series
to find the unique sound of magic that
fit their movie and as spell casting
became more and more prominent in the
second half of the series directors and
sound designers had to find unique sound
profiles not just for different spells
but also for different people and
different key events one of the things
that David Yates director of the final
four movies was really great at was
combining the incantations with the
spell sounds to create the sense that
the magic was leaping from people's
bodies just as they said the words my
favorite spell moment from the whole
series is at the beginning of order of
the Phoenix when Harry and Dudley are
run down by the Dementors listen to the
sound design here - when the Patronus
initiates
for me it's sound that makes that moment
so powerful the sound of Daniel
Radcliffe's voice mixed with the
flamethrower sound of the spell coming
in on the oh and patronum then giving
way to that familiar heavenly chorus
there's an urgency to this kind of spell
casting and a personal quality like the
spell is equivalent to the voice this
has brought home most of all in the
various examples of the death curse cast
in the final films
I feel like I say this all the time but
sound design is a deeply consequential
part of moviemaking people understand
what they see but they feel what they
hear by creating a diverse palette of
sounds whether it's explosive whooshes
wisps of wind or crackling lightning
mixed with voice these filmmakers and
sound designers brought Harry Potter to
life now that's what I call magic okay
that was a corny line I can't end on
that let's do Voldemort instead
[Applause]
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching one of the questions that you
guys ask me all the time is what
software I use to make these videos I
use Final Cut Pro 10 to edit the nerd
writer and there was actually a little
bit of an uproar when 10 came out
because Apple completely redesigned the
program from the previous version an
editing tool that I'd become an expert
on for over 10 years was just gone
eventually I learned how to use Final
Cut Pro 10 by watching a bunch of
YouTube videos but what I really wish I
had was something like today's sponsor
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community for creators with
more than 18,000 classes and graphic
design animation video game design and
Final Cut Pro 10 all the classes are
professional and understandable and
follow a clear learning curve a Premium
Membership begins around ten dollars a
month for unlimited access to all the
courses but the first 500 people to sign
up using the link in the description get
their first two months for free and
those two months you can easily learn
the skills you need to start a new hobby
or business definitely check it out
thanks guys I'll see you next time